can I confess something I was really
very scared to beat you me yes gorgeous
and talented in your connection with
David yeah there was a time when I
thought we were on the road to getting
back together and he met you
[Music]
Sarah Julia hi Julia
dolly say bye to mommy right there
you'll get used to Tessa
she's a Justin - nose down betta I know
she's Lilly's mother and of course I
respect that but it feels like I'm
stepping into her life
it's not easy all this change I get it
now you don't you couldn't possibly
don't worry in no time
you won't be back with mommy how well do
you really know do you you are a
survivor and what happened was not your
fault I only had David and Lily you took
everything away from me who's that your
flowers
what do you mean there's no record or
consent the arrangement take a deep
breath no one knows where you live
where's your ring how come you enter the
lair Annette she's messing with me I
made one mistake
there's no Dana cos Pilate Tessa come on
you're worthless
Julia
you always be worthless Tessa why are
you here David you should never have
brought her here
done with crazy
oh right and fried out me got you sent
miss banks the man is dead found in your
home look you see what this looks like
right Tess help she was the one behind
all of this enough is enough
are you threatening me yes I'm
threatening you this is my life it's
mine
you
you